hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my youtube channel today to talk
about one of my favorite things
happening on the internet right now
which is people freaking out over a
bikini stream oh there are like several
subtopics here that we need to address
there are women on the Internet hmm
twitch stream will make youtube videos
in revealing clothing on twitch in some
cases this has led to those women being
banned because it doesn't align with
that company all websites tons of usage
to is that it's not only the websites
that have a problem with this it makes a
lot of people really mad there are
several ideas thrown into this pool the
idea that women are exploiting
themselves for attention the idea that
women doing this makes other women who
don't do this look bad and I think there
are a lot of people who think that they
work harder or some personalities they
follow Wakata and a more deserving a
followers than women who supposedly get
them through bikini streaming or
whatever so there are a bunch of reasons
why people don't like this but as it
turns out that doesn't really matter
those people not liking it
and talking about it make people look
those people and more let's just go with
the example zoe burger is a girl who was
a twitch streamer who was banned from
twitch for bikini streaming i actually
first found out about zoe BOGO because
someone wrote an article and someone
else tweeted at me saying hey what do
you think of this girl and what she's
doing zoe I think was repeatedly banned
from twitch and then started using
YouTube instead to make videos and
started a thing that was hashtag nudes
at 1 million subs outraged obviously if
you read the comments on Zoe's videos
there are people saying really really
awful [ __ ] though but the point is
people keep watching and for every
person who's tweeted someone like me or
shared one of her things because they're
outraged by it you're building her
marketing machine Zoe got a million
subscribers in like a couple of months I
don't think that happened because she
shows her boobs on video I think that
happened because an outrage
she is doing something that she knew
people would hate and other youtubers
keep making the
goes about it in pot because they
realized that other people are also
searching her name because of the
controversy so if you see Zoe bug in a
video title you more likely to click on
it so there are people making money off
of her name and then some of them are
just actually outraged and then she is
also calling out the people who address
her or talk [ __ ] about her or talk about
her without giving her credit again
really smart marketing looks like anyone
who works in marketing is going to look
at this girl and be like yep you made a
lot of money at a name for yourself very
very very quickly good job and I
understand the reasons why people are
pissed about it but I mean I studied
marketing
I studied mass communication in school
from my perspective this is just so fun
to watch unfold I just really wanted to
make this video to be like look to
everyone who's getting angry you get in
plate to anyone who gets angry about
bikini stream is old girls and bras on
YouTube you get in plate
they know that's gonna happen they know
you're gonna get mad about it you're
gonna tell your friends and they're
gonna make more money from it but on
that note to the people getting plate I
kind of want you to continue getting
played because it's also very
entertaining to watch
Cowen's girl pedophile is just amazing
people with millions of subscribers
calling her a pedophile like god damn
you have any idea what's happening and
I've had people talk to me about this in
a way that it's like they think that ho
being successful takes away from any of
my chances of success on YouTube one
goal doing something and being
successful at it doesn't mean that you
can't do it differently and still be
successful at it but I would say you
know I haven't thrown about all of the
ethical issues with bikini streaming or
posting nudes freely or any of that kind
of stuff but immediate perspective is
that I don't think it really hurts
anyone you don't want that person to
succeed because you hate them because
they're not doing [ __ ] the right way in
your mind just don't talk about it don't
tell people about it but yeah I mean if
you do think there's something wrong
with it I would love for you to comment
below so that you can tell me why
because I'm sure that there are things I
hadn't even considered potties that
might be affected in ways that I hadn't
thought about that enough alrighty that
is it for me today you guys have to give
a shout out to the people who donated
after the last video which is Michael
Crozier jr. Santana
Tana and fury of pandas who said maybe a
fable impression so um you just gonna
stand there like a lemon chicken chaser
you chase chickens I will see you guys
next day